Oh Janine just liked one of my photos on
Instagram that's weird
I've never even talked to Janine like
why would she like one of my photos she
doesn't seem like a person that would
like just any photo and Instagram what's
this mean does she like me oh my god
that's it she hit the heart she gave me
her heart it's so obvious now how could
I've been so blind the signs liking my
photo and well just liking my photo if
that's your quirky way of asking me out
yes I will go out with you will I be
your boyfriend duh is that too upfront
well you were upfront enough to profess
your love to me on Instagram no one's
ever made me feel the way you make me
feel right now food tastes better
flowers smell better I don't have a care
in the world what color should my
wedding touch me did you just like Zacks
photo wait what's going on here oh are
you cheating on me okay
we can work through this we're gonna
have twins we're gonna be so happy no
wait no how could you Zach
why Zach was gonna be the best man at
our wedding
[ __ ] you to need we're done oh why Oh
Janine just like my photo on Instagram
[Music]
you
[Music]